we have Tom Curren he recovers the
Patriots first of all Tony thanks for
joining us and how big a role will
Patriot the politics play with the
Patriots tonight on media night I think
it's going to be really big and thank
you for having me I think when you look
at the landscape right now this past
weekend all that's happened and the fact
that Brady hasn't had the opportunity to
be laid bare in front of the national
media on this I think it the recipe is
there for him to be in the crosshairs of
the national media tonight now he's done
a very good job slow playing area and
keeping it all at arm's distance but I
don't think it's inevitable that it's
going to come up but he and I'm sure the
Patriots have a strategy right yeah dude
would they get together as a team to
have a strategy for tonight they
wouldn't necessarily do that it would
more be a blanket just don't do
something that we're going to have to
talk about for the next four days
because you uttered X Y or Z with Brady
i think is a personal strategy and i
think the captain's will pass it on to i
don't think that they muzzle them to the
point where if you have a view on
something that you want to express go
ahead and do that but don't make it over
the top so that we're talking about this
incessantly and other people are being
asked about it most likely to break
ranks on the Patriots would be who i
would say Martellus Bennett yeah as I
would say in a walk yeah you know walk
by Telus panic but if i look at brady
and belichick both have said that they
supported Donald Trump but and both are
going to be there for the media to at
least ask Robert Kraft has already said
how he feels about Donald Trump is it a
fair question to ask of these men in
this setting it is about immigration
with the Donald Trump look what happened
yes you should go to policy I think
that's a jump I mean that dadka guy was
completely you know preparing for the
super bowl and ask him can you weigh in
on this decision handed down you know
and all the things that are going I
think that's unfair night I wouldn't
want to go to a quarterback to get some
kind of
political analysis I mean I'm trying to
figure out what it means myself what's
real what's imagined where the reality
of things why why would I go to the
quarterback I would it is fair game to
ask him how uncomfortable it is
different aspects of his relationship
that have come to the fore over the
course of time but here's the
interesting thing I wrote about this
remember when Obama was running in 2008
and the Reverend Jeremiah Wright had had
some comments and this was a march of
2008 and through a very incendiary
comments anti-american comments and just
a few days later Obama gave a speech was
called a more perfect union speech and
in it he basically said exactly what
Brady has been saying there are people
who we have relationships with or
friendships with that say things that we
don't necessarily agree with or do
things that we don't agree with but that
doesn't mean we disavow them as friends
or people now it's the same thing boiled
down to Brady just saying why do I have
to talk about this I don't want to talk
about but do you believe him when he
said why is this a big deal we said that
on WEEI yeah and like why is this a big
deal about you know who I'm friends with
I think it's a little naive I do you
think that was but you on purpose that
he's saying this because he's an aware
guy he knows that yeah a big deal oh I
think he understands why it's a big deal
I think that he is stances why do I keep
being asked about this i can try to make
it clear i don't know what i'm talking
about its politics and i have no voice
in it what's interesting to me is from
his way of doing things he tends to guam
on to people and i think that over the
course of time whether it's orange over
your Donald Trump the Patriots have a
habit of attracting people to the team
the crafts don't chase them away Brady
doesn't mind celebrities around
Belichick doesn't either so over the
course of time trumped his become a
mascot and she's up there and he's
hanging around I could see if say you
don't be a tremendous tremendous favor
for me Tom if you would put a hat in
your locker I think it would be
for all of us yeah sure Donna I'm still
gonna play golf wherever I want to
whenever i want to but do the Patriots
go right to the White House on Monday
morning if they find a Super Bowl they
bring the White House to them all they
do is just the way it feels like Trump
would say you know let's skip a Polish
just come on yeah straight I did yeah
he'll imagine if he popped up on stage
so if we would spent so much time trying
to focus on Goodell and Brady if they
were in to have any interactions after
the game but I've said that having been
up there you hand out the Super Bowl
trophy oh you've had it up there I've
done it I think how many times have I
done it three times I've handed us the
Super Bowl trophy whoo-hoo trash as I
lost track there in fact I was up there
with Tommy I would sell any rom I
haven't been because it is a lofty perch
to be up there handing out that Super
Bowl trophy but as I've told people the
commissioners not he doesn't have
interaction he'll see everybody as they
come up say hello and then he's not
interviewing Brady or handing him a
Super Bowl trophy or the MVP he's not
involved in any of that stuff so I don't
know how awkward it you know it's going
to be awkward with the next day crafts
and Goodell that's where it's awkward
because he's saying here is your Super
Bowl trophy you know robert kraft and
crafts won't be able to help himself
because the landscape in new england
right now is people are still pissed off
that they feel as if he sold brady down
the river and everything he's done since
has been to try and recoup yes the
goodwill lost and if you look at this i
could absolutely see craft standing
there and saying and I'll this is
retribution and we finally got our
revenge and then that's just going to
feed the thing for however many more
months but it's never going to say she
ate people I think he's Tom Curren
comcast sportsnet New England covering
the Patriots what will the storyline be
though if the Patriots lose that Monday
morning hey you spent all that time
worrying about the drug thing with an
atom I don't know if it changes the
legacy conversation at all i think that
they're so far ahead now and i know that
they're not ahead of the field but in
for its four and three different that
much different than five and two for
brady it's
it can be different but how does he play
in the game will visit upon it as well I
mean people will continually point out
that Joe Montana was foreign-owned Super
Bowls he also played like ass and the
divisional playoff three different times
he was one and done it's not the
official designation Jennifer get up and
doing okay yeah Jenna play like I 89 90
91 this is going to be you know the
story lines will be Brady's lost it
Garoppolo is the future yeah yeah of
course and she will just be sitting
there is a handsome kid in knee oh yeah
he is but but that's part of is he
better looking than Brady in a
swashbuckling way yes wow wow does it
have the divot though doesn't have the
chin divot and I think that's a
separator and then all the great ones
have chin divots did you make their kids
out there trying to give themselves yeah
I'm giving me yes yes good up did
Montana have a chin divot Paulie of
course yeah yeah all the great win seven
yeah not a lot of chin divots up here
I'm noticing yeah a lot of great not a
lot of great ones up here no not at all
but I'm also i think the grappa lo
situations interesting is I don't see
him leaving it traded next year it feels
like a be the year after that wouldn't
it well he's up after the 2017 season so
he's under the Patriots control until
march of 2018 okay so what will happen
this year is the Patriots will not put a
for sale sign on him but it will be a
situation where teams will be able to
call and say well off you x y&z the
anticipation from the Garoppolo camp is
that it will be very aggressive people
be very interested in trying to find out
how they can extract it when you look at
the landscape its tony romo it's a very
[Music]
thin shallow draft for quarterback so
why not go and get this guy who's still
under contract yeah for another year you
think you'll be traded no not until
maybe august-september when somebody
finds out they go we can't go into the
season like this and then the Patriots
will have the urgency to use against
teams who like look we can enter the
season we had a what we fought with a
good team look at the Teddy Bridgewater
situation this year
on similar but also Kurt cousins with
that situation what's going to happen if
he's going to stay you know with Sam
with the erections or you know could San
Francisco be involved in this as well
yeah any number of teams could be great
to see as always thank you my friend
thank you stop by the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
[Music]